in the 1940s functional programming was
really minimalist for example boolean
who needs them what is a boolean for all
you do with the boolean is make a choice
that's its purpose how we make we can
make choices without boolean so let's
define two functions that we'll call
true and false
that will make choices if they're going
to make choices they've got to have at
least two things to choose between so
let's give them two arguments we'll call
them X and Y and now true we'll just
make the first choice and false we'll
make the second so back in the 40s
people thought let's represent boolean's
this way and well do these really work
as boolean if so we should be able to
define if-then-else and yes we can it's
easy we define if then else take a
boolean that then branch and the else
branch and it just calls the boolean to
make the choice between the dead and
else branches so that's great we've got
functions that behave like bullies we
don't need billions well if we don't
need boolean what about numbers who need
them okay let's talk about positive
integers here what's a positive integer
for well counting loop iterations let's
see if we can count loop iterations
without notes so what I want to do now
is I want to define to to be a function
that takes a loop body and a starting
value and just runs the loop twice so we
apply the function twice to the starting
value so that's going to be my
representation of two and one is going
to apply the loop body once and 0 is
going to apply a 0 times and so on so
you can see that for every positive
integer I can construct a function that
I claim corresponds to it but is this
actually a good way of representing
integers can I recover a normal integer
given one of these functions well sure I
can all I have to do is call the
function and give it a loop body
this is Haskell notation a loop body
that just Inc
a value starting from the value zero
severe if I sit in the Haskell
interpreter and I call my to function
and I give it the increment function and
zeros arguments what I get - I've
converted back to a normal integer so
there we are so I can represent natural
numbers this way can I do anything with
them well look I could add them together
I can do that like this how do I add em
and then well I'm going to want to
construct a loop that iterates f n plus
n times and I can do that just by
uttering f n times and then M times okay
that's addition Oh Oh what about
multiplication well if sequencing loops
gives me addition nesting loops give me
multiplication right so here I'm using
I'm going to iterate M times that's the
outer loop an inner loop that iterates F
n times how many times do I call F M
times n okay does this really work well
let's try it out so I can sit in the
Haskell interpreter again say let's
let's add one to multiply two by two
that should be five and then five times
I'll iterate the increment function on
zero sure enough we get five cool so I
can represent integers nothing to do
arithmetic on them well now there was a
time when every talk on functional
programming had to endure factorial
function here it is here is the
factorial function
I'll add 1940 okay so factorial n is
here's my if-then-else so that's my
using functions to model boolean's and
if n is zero that I'm going to return
that function I called one otherwise I'm
using my arithmetic implemented by
functions to multiply n by recursive
call of factorial with decrement n does
it work
sure in the Haskell interpreter I can
take factorial of
plus 2 times 2 that's factorial of 5 and
that many times I'll iterate
incrementing 0 and what do I get 120
that's right and it's not even terribly
slow so then we are there's factorial is
it a couple of auxiliary functions that
I haven't shown you there is zero is one
of them that's really easy how do I tell
it what are these functions represent 0
I iterate a loop body that returns false
and time starting from true so if n is 0
I'll get true if it's anything else I'll
get false and the other one I didn't
show you was decrementing and the less
said about that the better but you can
do it it works I promise you so there we
are we see that boolean x' integers and
actually any algebraic data type any
data structure could be entirely
replaced by functions that's cool
why well the guy who came up with this
was Alonzo Church these are the church
encodings of values and what Church
wanted to do was to show that functional
programming could be a foundation for
mathematics so you didn't need anything
else to start off with you could just
start off with functions and then
construct everything else that you might
want from them which is interesting
theoretically but this is not just a
theoretical interest it turns out that
early versions of the glasgow haskell
compiler actually implemented data
structures this way not numbers and
billions of course but other data
structures were implemented by functions
in this way because it turned out that
for a while there in the earth T's this
was actually the fastest way of doing it
believe it or not I remember the man who
discovered that had a different
functional language Milo
which he built from scratch and to save
time he had implemented data structures
using the church encodings and then one
day he decided to do it properly and
so he built in data structures as we
know and love them and the code went
slower there was a man called Yan
Fairburn so I should warn you I've shown
you at the hospital shell evaluating
these things if you try it at home
you're going to get an error message
gh CI says that the occurs check failed
we can't construct an infinite type blah
okay that sounds kind of serious it's a
little hard to tell just from that
message what the problem is though but
don't worry
gh CI is very helpful it tells you it
was expecting this type but it got this
one this is the first time I've had a
chance to use the three point font on
the slide okay so now you can see what
the problem was I suppose no don't worry
there's more these are the types of the
relevant bindings so going on here is
that the tricks I've shown you they work
very well in an untyped language and you
can do them in Haskell too but they go a
little bit beyond what the Haskell type
checker can figure out for itself so you
have to give a little bit of help you
have to add these two lexemes in red in
order to tell the compiler what the
correct type of the factorial function
is and if you do that then all the
examples I showed you just go through
perfectly so that's great so in the 40s
we could write functional programs but
we couldn't run them and that was kind
of a shame wasn't it
so then ran about 1960 John McCarthy
built the first list implementation and
suddenly it was possible to run
functional programs for the first time
here's the factorial function in Lisp
it's pretty similar to the nineteen
forties version so Lisp wasn't a purely
functional language but nevertheless you
could do a lot that we think of as
functional programming today right from
the start it had the map function which
was called map list in Lisp
you could map the factorial function
down a list of five numbers and sure
enough you would get the list of
factorials so higher-order functions
were in there from the start and now in
the early 60s there was a lot of work
going on in the research community to do
with functional programming but I want
to skip to a paper from 1965 which is a
real classic the next 700 programming
languages by Peter Landon
so Peter Landon was working for UNIVAC
at the time and he was aware of no less
than 1,700 different special programming
languages already by 1965
why were there 1,700 languages well they
were used in over 700 application areas
and Peter Landon thought that even 700
programming languages would be far too
many all that was needed was one his
programming language which he called I
swim for if you see what I mean plus
plus 700 different libraries that was
his idea so at this time every
application area would have its own
programming language and that was
unnecessary as Landon thought so he
presented I swim which was very nice
idealized language here is the factorial
function and I swim we haven't forgotten
that um and it was hugely influential as
an early functional language but I'm not
going to focus on ice cream so very much
as on another point that Peter Landon
made very strongly
Peter Landon said it's not only
important that we should be able to
express programs it's important that we
should be able to reason about them and
he was very interested in equivalences
laws that relate different programs like
this one that says that if you map f
over the reverse of a list that's the
same as reversing the result of mapping
F over the list now this law is nearly
true in Lisp it's not actually true
because if F has side effects then we're
going to be performing the calls in a
different order and so we may end up
with different
but Landon was very opposed to laws that
are nearly true he thought a law should
hold always without question and he even
discusses in his paper and whether or
not that's a good thing so you could
imagine somebody coming along and saying
well what's the point of having this law
what's the point of having two programs
that do exactly the same thing wouldn't
it be better if they did different
things because then you'd have a choice
Landon thunders no expressive power
should be by design rather than by
accident
yes Blackmun so this is really the first
paper that emphasized law so much I
think it's tremendously important idea
so let's give on a bit further again so
there was lots more research going on
and then in 1977 John Backus won the
Turing award now John Backus is somebody
that we everybody who studies computer
science has heard of because of Backus
normal form for grammars but he won the
Turing award because he was the man who
led the development of the first Fortran
compiler now even by 1977 it was quite
popular among computer scientists to be
a bit rude about Fortran but that
doesn't mean that one should forget what
an enormous achievement that first
compiler was it was the first compiler
that could generate better machine code
than a person could write and in those
days when computers were the expensive
part all people cared about was
efficiency so Fortran made high-level
language programming possible and that
was a huge step forward so it was a very
well-deserved Turing award and John
Backus when you win the Turing award you
get to give a lecture and write a paper
about it of course
John Backus could have written the paper
about how they developed the Fortran
compiler I'm sure that's what people
expect it I'm sure it would have been a
great paper he wrote one like that later
mr. award lecture he didn't talk about
Fortran at all he presented this talk
cam programming be liberated from the
von Lohmann style which is a manifesto
for functional programming and a
description of his idealized functional
programming language and this paper is a
wonderful read the opening paragraphs
are just fantastic
I've got then some of his text on my
slide he starts off conventional
programming languages are growing ever
more enormous but not stronger the queue
had ADA in mind in particular at that
time inherent defects at the most basic
level cause them to be both fat and weak
terrible isn't it what are these defects
their primitive word at a time style of
programming inherited from their common
ancestor the von Norman computer so he
was very negative about word at a time
programming and he said because the
processor operates on one word at a time
our programming languages operate on one
world word at a time and that creates
this bottleneck between what we want to
do in our data and by the bottom by this
bottleneck he was thinking of the bus
basically that connects a processor to
memory and he said I call this the von
Norman bottleneck this paper is where
that term comes from which has since
become still very well known so next
time you're going to buy a computer
don't ask how fast the buses ask how
fast the von Norman bottleneck is what
else is wrong with them their inability
to effectively use powerful combining
forms for building new programs from
existing ones
what combining forms was he thinking of
well I'm going to illustrate a couple of
his combining forms with diagrams so in
these diagrams boxes are going to
represent functions mapping inputs to
outputs and the inputs are coming from
the right might surprise you a little
bit at first
so what mother Baxter's combining for
what he called apply to all or which he
wrote as alpha F and the idea here is
that if you've got a function f you can
apply alpha to it and get a function
that takes a list of inputs and just
applies F to each one it's bad so that
was one of the forms that he thought was
important another one he called
construction so here the idea is that
you have a number of different functions
F 1 2 F 4 that's these colored boxes but
you give them all the same input oh by
making a construction of these functions
you get something that when given an
input passes it to each of the functions
and makes a list of the results what
else is wrong with conventional
languages their lack of useful
mathematical properties for reasoning
about programs so Bacchus was also very
concerned about laws here's one of his
laws this represents a composition of a
construction with another function G and
if you look at the diagram it's pretty
obvious this will do the same thing as
this provided G has no side effects it
doesn't matter whether we apply G once
and then duplicate the result or whether
we duplicate the input and then apply G
to it and that tells us that those two
terms at the top and the bottom in
Bacchus is a programming language F P
must always be equal and what about the
vaad normal bottleneck the word at a
time programming Welbeck has proposed
replacing programs like this this
computes the scalar product of two
vectors a and B and it's written in
Algol 60 so rather than write this
program which manipulates the vectors
one word at a time back is proposed
writing a scalar product function which
first of all takes a pair of vectors
transposes them into a vector of pairs
applies multiplication to all those
pairs and then folds addition down all
the results together and that gives you
the scalar product actually he wouldn't
have written it like this
he would have written it like this
little bit of a PLN be there perhaps but
the point is that this example
demonstrates very powerful ways to
compose simple components into complex
programs so this really was a landmark
paper the fact that John Backus the
father of Fortran devoted his Turing
Award lecture to a manifesto for
functional programming inspired a
generation of researchers myself among
them if you haven't read this paper
Google John Backus Turing Award today
and read it you will not regret doing so
I should say maybe that the first half
the paper is really the part that has
stood the test of time and being
tremendously influential the second half
of the paper was backus's ideas for
doing i/o in functional languages which
has not had the same impact it's the
first half of the paper really that I
absolutely strongly recommend everybody
should read that so this paper prompted
a huge amount of research by people who
are inspired among them Mary's PhD
supervisor Pete Henderson so let me tell
you about some of the work that he was
doing when we first met him
Peter had two loves functional
programming and the drawings of Usher
and he decided that he would like to
combine the two and if you look at this
a sure print which is them it's called
square limit you can see that it has
some kind of a recursive structure and
recursions the bread and butter of
functional programming Peter thought
wouldn't be great to construct this
picture by functional programming so in
those days then you did computer
graphics by sending drawing commands to
a plotter which moved a pen on a piece
of paper yes really it was that long ago
so graphics
would be very much word at a time one
drawing command at a time but Peterson
let's not do that let's set a picture be
a value so here's a value fish and the
students a picture is a value then you
can define functions that combine
pictures for example you make can make
this one by overlaying the original fish
with rotate rotate fish so here rotate
is a 90 degree rotation and if you do it
twice then we rotate the fish around and
then they fit together and the fact that
they fit is Ash's genius so that's cool
is something else we can do so here
we've got the original fish and two
smaller copies this this one is the
original fish
this one is fish two and fish two is a
45 degree rotation of the original fish
and it's also shrunk a little bit in
order to fit in there in the same box so
it's actually being rotated 45 degrees
and then flipped around the y-axis and
then this is fish 3 which is the further
rotation of fish 2 and now we've got a
fish and some smaller fish that reminds
us of the original print doesn't it
let's keep going what else can we do
well here we've taken that smaller fish
fish 2 and just put it together four
times in four different rotations and we
get this nice little picture of fish
swimming in a circle so Peter went on to
define more and more operations for
combining pictures like quartet that
would take four pictures and draw them
in the full court of a square or cycle
that would take one picture and draw
that in the four quarters of the square
but with a rotation applied to make them
kind of swim around and if you have an
implementation of these things it's
great fun to play with you can just
strip whatever you like here's here
we've taken the T image with efficient
two little ones and just cycle it around
here I've made a quartet of this thing
so as you never drew this but it doesn't
matter we can make our own pictures
whatever we feel like so in order to
construct the final picture then Peter
wanted to make an edge so here we've
made a quartet of to empty pictures
that's what nil is supposed to be you
can see the gaps up there and that T
picture in one of its rotations and you
could see that here we've got larger
things on the inside and smaller fish on
the outside but really we'd like to have
even smaller fish up here wouldn't we so
let's take this picture let's call it
side 1 and then let's make this picture
where we replace the empty pictures by
smaller copies of Sidewalk so that code
does that and you can see that by
continuing in this way we're going to be
able to get smaller and smaller fish
protein the side of the picture need a
corner as well let's use this picture as
the corner so once again I've got a
corner with three empty squares around
it and now if I call this corner one and
put copies of that in the empty squares
will get corner to where the fish are
getting a bit smaller and by repeating
this process once again I can make
smaller and smaller and smaller fish
approaching the the corner so Peter
constructed square limit at the end from
the picture you this side and this
corner in a no net I haven't showed you
the definition that's a square divided
into nine little squares so we've got a
corner in each corner and we've got the
side on each of the sides and there's a
u thing in the middle and what does that
give you square limit do you remember
the original picture not bad eh that's
pretty close
so this was a delightful fun exercise
but we didn't didn't stop there
because he still had to implement
pictures somehow let's see how can we
represent pictures hmm well we need some
kind of complex data structure do we
know let's let pictures be functions so
Peters idea here was to say well when we
draw a picture we have to end up at the
end of the day with a list of drawing
commands but let's like a picture be a
function that constructs that list and
we might want to draw a picture in a
variety of places and in a variety of
sizes so let's let a picture just be a
function that takes three vectors a B
and C that specify a box on the plane
okay so vector a specifies where the
bottom left-hand corner is and then B
and C specify the edges of the box and
then a picture will return drawing
commands that draw itself within that
box so the really nice thing about
representing pictures as functions is
that it made picture combinations really
easy to define so here's how you might
overlay two pictures you just draw them
both in the same box and take the union
of the drawing commands here's how you
put picture P beside picture Q so just
to make this easier to understand take
the box ABC we divide it into two boxes
and you figure out what the vectors
there need to be and then we draw P in
the left box and Q in the right box and
take the Union you can even rotate a
picture by fiddling with the vectors
okay so if we take this Square and
rotate it we can see that it's for
bottom left hand corner is going to end
up here and we have to swap they
actually is B and C and negate the B one
that gives us a 90-degree anti-clockwise
rotating so Peter was able to define his
picture combinators really easily and
thanks to those simple definitions he
could also easily prove laws about them
like this one that if you put P above Q
and rotate it you get the
same result as if you rotate P and
rotate Q and put them beside each other
and that's a little bit of simple
algebra because the implementations of
these functions are so simple and Peter
studied those laws very much and he says
this in the paper it seems there's a
positive correlation between simplicity
of the rules the laws and the quality of
the algebra as a description tool in
other words by making sure that the
functions he defined had these nice
properties he got a language with his
pictures that was more expressive and
nicer to use so I think this is a really
great example of functional programming
at its best and we've seen a number of
examples of ideas coming back again and
again the idea of programming with the
whole value the whole picture the whole
vector the whole array not word by word
of defining combining forms like map and
construction and overlay and of using
the algebra the laws as a litmus test to
guide the design of these combined forms
and another idea dating back to church
of using functions representations which
is tremendously important so I want to
very quickly now hop hop ahead to a
paper from 1994 which is a bit less well
known but which I really like and meant
a great deal to me it's called the
somewhat clumsy name high school versus
a diverse of C++ versus orc versus dot
dot dot so this paper originates from a
big DARPA product project in software
prototyping software prototyping was
very trendy at that time Siddartha
wanted to support work on it and you
couldn't get DARPA funding to write
Haskell programs for real use in those
days but Paul got some DARPA money
through using Haskell to build software
prototypes and many other people got got
money from the same project so then at
some point the DARPA adabo wanted to
evaluate how well people were doing so
they gave every
the same problem to prototype and they
were to record how much code they had to
write and how long it took the problem
was a geometric one so it involved
defining regions in the plane with
complex shapes and darpa being darpur
these regions had names like weapon
doctrine and slave doctrine and there
are points in here called hostile
aircraft and so on so the prototype was
supposed to input a description of this
stuff and then applies it and outputs
things that would say you know the
commercial aircraft was in the engage
ability zone and so on Mark Jones got
the job of implementing this prototype
in Haskell you can see that the key
thing here is you have to work with
regions with complex shapes you've got a
represent region somehow there are lots
of different shapes of them it could be
a very complex data structure how do you
think Mark Jones represented a region a
function from point to ball and that
made the Combinator's own regions
extremely easy to define I mean the
outside of a region it's just you know
not of what the region would return the
intersection the Union they're really
easy to define
and as a result Mark's prototype was
very very tiny I don't know if you can
read this but this is Mark's code he
wrote 85 lines of code the Eider
solution was over 760 lines C++ 1,100
lines and there are there are some
others that approach 85 lines many of
them didn't work though Marx did in fact
when when Mark solution was submitted
the evaluators at first thought he
hadn't solved the problem he's just
written down a specification where's the
code but it was actually executive or
what I think is a real shame is that
Mark had written 29 lines of type
signatures and typesetter names but the
type checker would have inferred by
itself so his solution could have been
29 lines smaller
so anyway when these results came in to
the evaluators they thought there's
something funny going on they're
cheating you might see that Haskell
appears to this list twice so what's the
second one the evaluators gave the same
problem to a graduate student somewhere
else without telling Paul they just said
okay you've got eight days to learn
Haskell then see if you can solve the
problem and the student did the second
smallest solution how about that it's
almost twice as large as Marc's well
he's only had eight days to learn
Haskell but it was the second-best
solution so you would have thought at
this point DARPA would say WOW Haskell
is clearly the best prototyping language
but they didn't they said it's too cute
for its own good
higher-order functions are just a trick
probably not useful in other contexts oh
well so much for that let me go back in
time a little bit and I want to talk
about another pair of classic papers
that really inspired me and these were
the two papers both came out in 1976
that introduced and publicized lazy
evaluation there we're lazy evaluation
had been discovered before this but
these were the two papers that put it on
the map and one of the guys was Peter
Henderson Mary supervisor so I was
really inspired by the idea of lazy
evaluation because it meant that the
whole value that we've been talking
about could be infinite so a program
committed may plate a whole value that
would be the infinite list of natural
numbers or the list of iterations of a
function all right so here's f apply
zero times one time two times how many
iterations all of them now of course
this doesn't mean that any single
program would compute all of them but
the choice of how many to compute is
left to the consumer this def
can compute any number of iterations of
that as many as you want
it's up to the consumer how many you get
and I was very excited about the
possibility of separating the decision
of how many things to compute from the
coat that told you how to compute them
here's an example of a consumer for
numerical methods I had studied
numerical analysis without very much
success a few years earlier but one of
the things I had learned is that
numerical methods often take the limit
of a sequence of approximations so let's
just make that a consumer limit get an
infinite list of approximations and
returns the first one it finds where
where the distance between
approximations is less than Epsilon so
now we've got a part of many numerical
algorithms but expressed as a reusable
separate function here's the
newton-raphson square root algorithm
that starts from some value let's say
1.0 and compute successive
approximations here's the next function
that does that so I can compute new s
and square roots just by iterating the
next function until I reach the limit
and so I'm able to separate the
computation of the approximations from
taking the limit
here's code for computing a numerical
derivative so the derivative is the
limit of the slope of the graph as
points get closer and closer together so
let's compute a series of HS by starting
from one and making them smaller and
smaller and then let's map a slope
calculation over that and take the limit
and the convergence check can be the
same code even though the algorithm for
computing the approximations is
different so I thought this was great
actually there's something even cooler
you can do so differentiation is done by
taking the limit of a slope as H gets
smaller and smaller integration is done
by taking the limit of a sum of areas as
H gets smaller and smaller here's of the
trapezium rule for integration results
in that
so in both cases we've got something an
age that is getting smaller and smaller
okay
think back to your numerical analysis
courses when you do something like this
the result that you get can be expressed
as a plus B times some power of H where
a is the right answer and B times a to
the N is the error term so suppose we
take two successive approximations now
we've got two values we know what ages
in each case we've got two two
simultaneous equations for a and B we
can just solve them right and if what if
we solve them what we get will we get B
which we don't really care about but we
can a which is the right answer so we
can take a sequence of approximations
and just take the first two and compute
the right answer from them who needs the
rest of them okay well it's not quite as
brilliant as this because this form is
only an approximation happens is that we
get a much more accurate answer than
either of these two but it's not
completely right but never mind we could
take the next two and do it again so we
can make a new sequence of
approximations which converges faster
it's a better numerical method and we
can write a function that does that so
here is a really fast function for
computing derivatives we make the
initial approximations in the same way
as before
we improve it a couple of times and
improving the first removing the first
order of error term and the second or
error term now it converges really
quickly we'll take the limit isn't that
sweet and everything is programmed
separately everything is reusable here
thanks to whole value programming if you
do this with integration which is a much
more expensive operation you get a
really good numerical integration
algorithm very very easily so this is
some of the stuff that appears in my
paper why functional programming matters
and the basic idea that the paper uses
again and again is that of
connecting a consumer and the producer
with lazy evaluation so the consumer
demands values and then the producer
generates them so I've shown you how we
can do that with numerical
approximations in the paper I also show
that you can represent a search space in
at the same lazy manner and then the
consumer becomes the search strategy
that decides which parts of the search
space we need to compute and explore and
in the paper I used that to implement
the alpha-beta algorithm for Norton
crosses my implementation was extremely
slow so this was about the most complex
game I could solve this time but I was
able to program the alpha-beta heuristic
as a separate function whereas all the
presentations I'd seen before hand had
to make the alpha-beta part with the
construction of a game tree and there's
one more paper I've used this idea again
and again during my career there's one
more paper that I want to show you that
uses the same idea it's the quick Chek
paper so for those of you who haven't
seen quick check the idea is that you
test your program by writing general
properties like this one so here's the
property you reverse that just cept for
any axis that is a list of integers if
we take X's and reverse it twice then we
get back the original no list and if you
give that quick check it'll generate a
hundred random values by default run the
test for each of them and in this case
all the tests pass so that's great
what's more interesting is what happens
if the property is not true so here's a
wrong property that says that if you
reverse a list you get itself and of
course that's not true for all lists and
in that case quick check quickly finds a
random list for which it's not true such
as this one but you can see that that
could be hard to debug so then it goes
up and to simplify the failing test and
finally ends up reporting a minimal case
that
in this case just a list 0 1 this is the
smallest list that falsifies this
property why is it smallest well if we
removed either the 0 or the 1 we get a 1
element list that is its own reversal
why is it 0 and 1 well if we replace the
1 by 0 so we had 0 0 we've got another
list that is its own reversal so this is
the simplest case that fails and these
are the cases the quick check presents
to the user for further debugging so how
does it work well the property defines a
space of all possible tests and then the
quick check search strategy is consumer
that traverses that space running the
tests first of all at random and then
systematically to find the smallest
possible case ok so I think in the
interest of time I will skip over some
hardware stuff except and to tell you
let's talk about hardware for a little
while so something else that we'll all
remember from around this time is the
Intel Pentium bug here's a calculation
you could drop on any processor we take
some number 419 something divided by
another one 314 then multiply it by the
314 one again so this should give us
back the original number we subtract it
from itself and of course we can get 0
which you do on modern processors and
you should have on Intel's processors
but as well but on the faulty Pentiums
you got 256 so this wasn't good of
course and for a while
Intel tried to pass it off saying was
very unlikely to happen and it's nearly
right
but in the end they had to replace
enormous numbers of Pentiums it cost
them four hundred and seventy five
million dollars there's a lot of money
even for Intel and of course they then
they had all these flawed Pentiums what
did they do with him simple they put
them into key rings and every member of
staff got one of these hearings at the
time I've seen one of these on the back
they say bad companies are destroyed by
crises good companies survive them great
companies are improved by them so what
was the improvement the improvement was
they recruited this man Karl seeker who
went to Intel to build his own lazy
functional language FL which was
specially designed for doing proofs
about hardware that had some facilities
and using that he built his fort a
system that has thousands of users
inside Intel this is what they used to
verify Intel microprocessors and make
sure that Pentium boat will never happen
again so FL it's used as a design
language specification language for
scripting for all the formal
verification tools and so on and it's
also the language that the tools prove
things about though functional
programming is really at the heart of
Intel's approach to formally verifying
circuits so why hasn't there been
another Pentium bug at least in part
it's thanks to functional programming
that's good to know
on the subject of hardware I also want
to just mention a language called blue
spec which is Haskell for Hardware
basically and this is the brainchild of
Arvind at MIT which combines Haskell for
the large-scale structure of hardware
description and some atomic transition
rules from which the compiler can infer
parallelism to generate very log that
goes into industry standard tools for
synthesis after that so blue spec lets
you write write your hardware in Haskell
basically
and the code you get is often faster
than handwritten code as functional
programming always does by simplifying
the task of just making things work
it gives designers more time to use
better algorithms and it's made
architectural change of designs are
someone very easy to do it's a very nice
paper about this by Nikhil who is the
CTO of the blue speck company and
there's a reference there and of course
blue speck is essentially a kind of
Haskell so it has quick check this is
web by Matthew Naylor and more in
Cambridge and you can take that the blue
speck quick check and generate and
shrink tests on the chip and this blows
away hardware designers I mean our
designers are used to maybe having some
support for testing on a chip but having
the whole process where the chip just
outputs by the way I don't work for this
input that that's just black magic so I
think that's really cool so we've made a
very long journey starting from church
numerals and coming all the way to
Haskell and quick check running on a on
a chip but throughout this whole journey
then there are a number of ideas that
have come back again and again and again
programming with the whole values not
we're out at a time
powerful combining forms that satisfies
simple laws and using functions as
representations and I think these four
ideas pervade good functional
programming and they've delivered a
whole lot of value over the years so I
think we would have made back as proud
thank you
[Applause]